hello friends welcome to another episode
of impaired
I am JC cariah's and I am Chris cope we
are your co-host on this journey through
debauchery I am one of the world's
biggest alcoholics and I'm one of
biggest earners you'll ever meet what we
like to do on this show is bring our
buddies on and we all get impaired we
play a bunch of games we get all goofy
come into our booth with us
[Applause]
wagon another 60 pounds of
in God's will this little boy made his
TV debut on Conan in 2012 but hasn't
been back because they won't respond to
his goddamn emails born and raised in
Los Angeles California diagnosed with
Tourette syndrome at the age of four his
hair started receding in 25 but hey
everybody welcome I would like to
introduce our this week's our guests I'm
really high backwards to all of them I
have a disability yes
smokes so much his [ __ ] brain is made
of mush that's a real disability I'm
leaving hi guys here our guest you bet
him a second ago we got Ralph Guerra
everybody we got Samuel J Cairo in the
building everybody I use and now here so
here's a fun thing we like to do every
single impaired episode we start with
the cheers and then we like alright I
just think we got taken down here
through this basement I just too big as
dudes like no you cute kids are gonna
come in here we're gonna get your real
drum you out there Moses said he needed
some red wine huh yeah it's true you
need ice no yeah I know what Ice giving
you the ice is not helping I didn't see
him wash his hands actually extra flavor
there's also an extra thing that during
every episode there's a secret word and
we don't know what it is so as long as
but soon as someone says Isis Christ I
thought I'm supposed to do him okay that
looks like a punch bowl well good for
you
now he's gonna add coca-cola do it cuz
around this man
it's classy he's a very classy man
it's classy people drink it all the time
in Spain yeah can I try that I got to
try that well soon as you put coca-cola
in and of course Christmas Oh
so yeah Christmas talking about the
secret word there is a word at a name
point during the episode you're gonna
hear this if we say it right oh sweet
Christ that's terrible you guys get the
way the game works if you hear ok can
you drink one of us it said the secret
word
yep ok so you guys know the single word
is we do know we don't know no lime sac
who picked the word take the word this
week who picked the [ __ ] word
Rachel pick the word everybody Wow all
right welcome to another hope it's good
I made it you know yeah just bad you
yeah you do what's going on with you
guys what's new just chillin don't you
just move back to LA right yeah New York
for a long time yes Angeles had a baby a
baby wife is always in charge anyways
yeah more medicine that's a baby
it tastes like cough syrup you left in
your car for a week I think it tastes
delicious
no it's really bad dude yeah like this
is it like a thing I'm saying for the
cameras it's not good well that hurts my
feelings do you want that this looks
like Chris's blood
like why is it so thin what is this
Mountain Dew Code Red like we need
someone who's has blood type Mountain
Dew Code Red
we need to catch a West Virginian
snowboarder with the same kids I'm sorry
but I'll drink it I'm better than his
punch of Coca Cola here this is a classy
drink that looks summer hold of the
person invention now we all live in LA
and I think that's something we like to
do every episode we talk [ __ ] about the
cities that we're from we called
hometown harassment mm-hmm so I think
that because we all live here it's
pretty it's pretty dead horse we'd be
beating huh yeah it's a lot of traffic
the worst part about LA is all the
people that moved here from other places
to be honest no but there is a benefit
though I love the fact that every time
someone moves out of LA I get to keep
some of their stuff we did just get a
grill I literally ate freedom I was like
I I'm giving up my dreams I'm like what
about that Webber you don't throw that
away you can't put down your car with
the rest of your dreams all that lost
hope in the trunk ah I'm told Karen I
paid enough a month to have that
attitude I'll be I got a free grill so I
love the fact that when people leave La
I'll sit in traffic if every two years I
get a free grill by proxy I got a free
grill too yeah
Roxy there's someone under here
I don't like this place at all
you've heard of what's in the box god
it's like wet under there it's called oh
yeah drink more of that there's the last
you guess are you look at this [ __ ] I
still don't understand the it just needs
more ice
yeah that's what'll fix that's got the
callee [ __ ]
yeah google it what's that mean
Jenni drink in Spanish come on Co man
Street Street yeah Nelson all right you
guys wanna play a game
sure yes yeah fine also we've dragged by
weight again we should guess that damn
secret were denied a chance we can't the
fact that we haven't said it it's pretty
crazy
yeah well cuz again I feel like it's
gonna be in that range of like booze or
darling alcohol table man table man
crazy again sorry I keep touching you
guys I'm just scared that's okay
that's how you do our basement yeah um
we're gonna play a game called up blind
artists everybody it's a real fun game
huh basically what we're gonna do is
we're all gonna go back to back okay
me and Chris are gonna put blindfolds
over us okay and then we're gonna be
handed an object okay and we're gonna
describe it to you guys okay each of you
is gonna try and draw it
I know Evers closest so we're sitting
back to back - so Rachel you're gonna
judge - you're gonna pick the winner
cool so you guys get to draw as we
explain it to you dope
right okay do it bringing those bringing
those objects in those and they give you
guys something we have the obvious
huh okay you guys are drawing the
curtains that kids name for you that was
gonna be bad it's always gonna be bad
you guys got a turn okay
you spread yours and okay so I already
like the way that we forwards are happy
you spread yours so they're touching
something and they're telling us what
what it is right so you're drawing what
I'm saying Ralph we're a team
Oh gotcha I don't want to win sure
because this is what normal people do we
drink you can't see what I have right no
a hammer can okay out of the bag okay so
Ralph yeah it's a it's like a it's got a
[Music]
pian so it feels like it's just a big
giant continent no wife okay put your
head against my hair oh okay believe
what I'm holding perfect all right yeah
say done Holly how does a joint joint
right now draw two circular ridges like
it's a UH like like a like a vampire's
mouth is there a time frame cuz yeah
we're gonna run out of it I think okay I
am think I'm getting there do you think
you think about it for cracking nuts
Ralph
no it's our look like it hot
I'm just gonna draw something and then
we'll see if we're okay
all right and yeah there it is that's
time all right I think I got it so do we
turn around that's not bad okay cuz look
it's got teeth like yeah yeah that's a
lot better though Oh Rachel who won [ __ ]
dammit Ralph
I win contests Cobra Kai Cobra Kai
Madison for winners I think I'm gonna
leave this honor what to be fair of what
I described so that's pretty goddamn
auntie [ __ ] Ruben - I said it was too
[ __ ] engine yeah
he drew a stapler that it's also a
vampire yeah it looks like a hot dog
hole just like it is for cracking nuts
I said nut cracker he did I said do you
know what a nut cracker eighties he said
I mean you mean the guy with the shitty
boot bud no that's uh that's Steve
Madden this part
style mesh that's the style part yeah
like have you never been a fashion week
[ __ ] idiot
why no you think you know what happened
around drew one boot and then decided it
was a cuppa tea drew a cup and then I at
first I just felt this you know and I
was like well okay dad it's a cup yeah
some big-ass beer some improvised
pictionary hello you won and did you
enjoy your division and a half of it
well give me the rest of your medicine
all right oh it's been a JC like
watching other you lost I should have
gotten some no no wrong your generation
fine
what's don't say your generation yeah
these [ __ ] five years younger than
you go medicine help oh why did I ask
for it cuz you [ __ ] asked for it yeah
bellyache now enjoy come just turn into
a southern mom the bell in the go enjoy
sorry your Pappy died just like your
father down at the mill I'm gonna leave
medicine to punish people for later yeah
in case you said a magic one in case
there's more medicine medicine well is
the word like like a college word that
we would never get oh no you normally
it's like something indica donut cheeto
no she's getting no come here
we're way off guys we're not hot
[ __ ] impaired god damnit that'd be the
funniest thing if we didn't get the
[ __ ] name of the show no good be
pretty setting we said welcome to
something well you know what guys I
think we've been out here long enough
that maybe we need a treat let's jump
into our next segment what we like to
call wasting there it is boys and girls
this is where we make a delicious monkey
treat based on what's kind of left over
in your kitchen if you're seeking
something you need to eat but you got
just a random assortment of items and
you just kind of need to slap it
together
that's what we got for you you know like
oh god why are we here why are we here
your medicine I thought we were gonna do
Scrabble
you guys made it sound so fun on the
phone Jesus I'm just scared
ralph guerra let's cut to a little
segment we like to call
[Music]
I want to try it now Chris explain what
everyone's looking at you know the
audience has seen it but explain to our
guess what this is Mexican crepes
it's something that I've had such an
offensive title and I think we can
figure out his name up with it is it um
but it's really good I I put them a
couple times pretty [ __ ] up and just
had tortilla and like Nutella laying
around a banana and just you make it
real quick your microwave and it's
really good it's just really good isn't
it smells good
it look I mean oh I don't like anything
why does it look like tremor blood like
when you cut open a tremor yes it is I
promise
it's way no that's honey on top of that
takes away the pocket oh my god it's
like it's like as heavy as a diaper like
it same concerns everything about this
is a diaper Sam I came here to get away
from my child
oh man much like drippings so alright do
we have to eat it yeah oh man mine's
dripping Allah it's pretty good I never
thought I'd say this but I'd rather have
more medicine well we can we can provide
you with more lettuce it down oh my god
it's bleeding honey it's pretty damn
tasty I try no the [ __ ] just I don't
know he just took a bite of the tortilla
all right I'll take
take a look is there any sort of nap
good tissue or tears I don't know how
you guys made that much
I took the smallest bite and I'm still
just mad because we're men it's just all
right well everybody cheers we hit it
all right
save your hand everybody dolly so let's
say it one more time
delicious yeah and words should have
never been said this segment I know they
knew we were gonna say no cuz JC says
that a lot you got a lot of fun
Trevor black gravelly blood in your
beard and you know they made five of
them [ __ ] let me tell you my
top five favorite movies tremors 1
tremors two tremors three tremors 411 an
inside job that's always there another
kind of file when we bring JC you want
to play two truths and a lie yes I'll
explain that basically so everybody here
is gonna come up with two truths and a
lie and we're gonna share them and then
we're gonna figure you're gonna guess on
which one's the truth and which one's a
lie JC all right
right imma love us to eat this right
take it eat them so you understand the
game yeah okay it's in the title yes
that's why I explain I feel like there's
like three people who watch this like
don't understand and cooks like let me
tell you guys gather around
Billy Tommy Tommy there yep in college I
dated a woman who was involved with
equestrian sports mm-hmm in high school
I sold weed to make extra money for my
family and finally I can say the
alphabet backwards alphabets the life
everyone has to say their gift you I
think the equestrians a lie okay we got
two cousins
I mean I'm gonna agree with Sam and go
alphabet backwards you're 100% correct I
cannot say the alphabet backwards
really I got a smoke all right [ __ ] so
what you did did a girl that was an
equestrian major she wasn't a major she
just helped with the she helped with the
horses right yes sir
okay rothgery two truths and a lie
that's true I don't know how to ride a
bicycle I've never been to Hawaii and I
have never been to Hawaii and I've had a
relationship with a Sky Drive that
skydiving instructor this guy I think I
think automatically I have to go see now
just something just on the cusp of all
that the fact that he [ __ ] the last
one up makes me feel like that one's the
reach but logic
I think it's cuz he was going for
something else right yeah like so okay
what are you feeling I feel like I know
Ralph enough and he does weird [ __ ] like
that
okay find a skydiving instructor and a
nerd okay we've seen it he'd find her
he'd find her yeah he wouldn't find her
skydiving
are you sure it by her wind sir yeah
yeah do you guys think I'm doing this
extreme stuff too
what was I wearing goddamnit I'm just on
the beach like Oh gnarly Chris what do
you feeling man I think you're I think
you're I think your lie is the skydiver
instructor
okay so is that your vote is that your
vote no mine is Hawaii Hawaii your vote
is you've never dated a skydiving
instructor they're an elite class of
their own and they would not be with the
likes of you you know what I feel like
Ralph Guerra is an odd person and he
would go the least likely answer is the
answer I would say Ralph doesn't know
how to ride a [ __ ] bike so the lie is
what I have to say the lie is what you
have to say I was so cocky with the
title of the game right okay
which one was I I've never I've never
had a relationship with this guy that
makes a Fuss I don't know how to ride a
bike have you been no I said I don't
know how to but I don't know how to
write about oh you said I don't know how
to ride a bike yeah I should listen
better they just can I won't lose game
you know what medicine for game and no
one's gonna teach me people have tried
Oh take a full one because medicine is
terrible yeah Jim all right I'm not
gonna be great at this game better gonna
try okay oh man um I didn't lose my
virginity till I was 21 but when I did I
was really good at it
alright alright first fry I lost my
virginity in a church parking lot and so
ok ok I lost my virginity in a Kia I
liked that he stayed all virginity yeah
it was a full story I wanted to make
yeah that's dope that's a great [ __ ]
so the first one was I lost my virginity
when I was 21 but when I did I was
really good at it yeah Sam's poker face
Sam just makes bubbles waiting for
somebody to bring he's the first guy I'm
enjoying myself he looks like the first
guy that dies in Rambo comes out I think
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay the wash I know it's ringing just
say scramble the line I think oh [ __ ]
was it yours or hers yeah what kind of
Sion as a hatchback I remember away it
was really small we haven't told Wetzel
pretzel everybody's xB I know that
because I have an expiation have you sex
in your XP I certainly do not go in
there all the time
sorry oh boy me all right your turn I'll
start I I took karate as a kid oh honey
nein gonna bully you know mo we get your
karate classes they never gonna bully
you see this three ninjas thing is
getting [ __ ] spot-on
look at these [ __ ] IMDB I swear
to God that first movies three ninjas
all right dick karate we're out I have
won $10,000 on a game show
okay I lost my virginity at the age of
18 I already know this one
Ralph you already know it you no no no I
mean I think I could guess it but
that's right you know it's right you got
any idea no no don't go don't make the
guest just like you what do you feel
like I think the the karate thing feels
cuz it's hilarious yeah and he does this
a lot yeah first time you've I've seen
him with you are we gonna lean the other
time I've done this I feel like I was at
a pool party the $10,000 is oddly
specific I'm gonna say 18 cuz I feel
like you were younger that's what you're
very mature he did not lose his
virginity at 18 Wow
100% he didn't a loser's version 18 Wow
that dude that dude was 12 and I was a
weirdo every round every round I was
guessed correctly by everybody first and
then I hit wrong on each of your stories
I'm gonna say they Chris did not win
$10,000 on the game show okay so the lie
is that I lost my virginity eighteen son
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] for fifteen and a
half everyone I won $10,000 on a
celebrity name game it's too specific I
think that's my manager texted me to
tell me I'm terrible and get guessing
walk upstairs get out of there but stop
guessing [ __ ] I know I'm sorry
it's okay yes you look good last time
where were you when you had lost your
virginity start Florida 15
oh goodness I you know you just know oh
god she's like I got all I could I never
done it before the view the view thrusts
that occurred there's more Naturals yeah
I look like I was getting electrocuted
the first time I owe
looks like you start it the first time
you have sex it's just like you're
halfway to come and before you even get
your pants off you know so the whole
time it's just it just that's just
please don't please don't please don't
please don't please don't
what do you think about when you're not
trying to 15 nothing no thoughts on
earth we're gonna stop it was occurring
yeah you just so happy that someone I
wasn't doing anything like Oh baseball
it was more just like oh thank god
that's over with it was very it's so
weird that mentality like men have more
we like we like the quicker we get it
over there quickly feel better about
ourselves this is turning it's like a
real time behind like peanut butter
pizzas we're gonna come back from the
we're gonna come back from the
commercial and we're gonna talk more
about how it feels to love okay on this
next episode of the view it's say at
least we had a laugh in the bag that's
all bad I'm gonna do be out so much
[ __ ] honey you're welcome yeah
am i all right guys I think we're gonna
jump into our final BYOB be your
bartender basically is the production
teams gonna give us a drink we name
we've never heard of we don't know what
it is and we're gonna have to make our
version of what we think that cocktail
is whoever comes closest kind of wins I
mean you also we're gonna give points
based on taste you know Casey goddamn it
Chris is terrible hi guys we're gonna
play a game called beer on bartender
we're gonna get a cocktail name from the
production so they're gonna tell us what
it is everyone here is gonna try and
make that drink and then afterwards I'm
gonna taste all of them and choose which
one I think tastes the best then we're
gonna find out what's actually in the
cocktail and we're gonna find out who
the other winner is and find out it was
closest to that cocktail listen all
right gang let's find out our cocktail
let's get that name and our clue okay
all right gang now they're going to give
us a timer okay
so we're all gonna be trying to work
together but against each other for what
we're going after the best White Russian
we're trying to make a White Russian
okay I already know how to make it I
thought we had this very confident I'm
gonna make a White Russian
anybody else feel good about it I'm very
confident well yeah I thought we were
gonna drink the drink guess what it was
and then have to make it well but now
that I know it's a White Russian right
it's a brand-new Rosa red oh you know it
yeah feel good yeah that was my first
drink let's put that time around the
clock come on I'm gonna bring us a
little closer because Chris
hey you know guys all right sorry right
there yeah okay all right oh come on we
all gets billion messy in this
[ __ ] this is gonna be delicious
I can't wait to taste them all we're not
gonna find out whether it makes the
tastiest one real soon oh oh my god that
is black oh man
there's ice in mine I know mine's pretty
dark I know my Sam oh my god Sam I threw
my thing
I know it almost hit me oh you can just
it's
just sim sorry we're gonna have to let
you go but I made a nice coffee I
brought out port oh my it's pretty dark
too
there's not a great amount in here okay
now everyone go ahead set up and set him
over here come over
mm-hmm let's start I want to drink my
own [ __ ] hold on bud come on what
Christmas sir Chris it's consistency and
mâche din the light lets me know that
the dude would be pretty [ __ ] happy
I think he'd abide I think he would
abide my friend [ __ ] him all right
take you sit it's delicious it's a
fantastic alabaster it's a thicker than
I like it sorry you know that it's good
oh my god it's my it's mud it looks I
mean I'm going to drink it yeah gonna
happen
before you do can I remind everybody
that I did win Sam would like everyone
to know when they look at this drink
that he won the picture game thank you
yeah he killed it Thanks
good god what are you getting go down
with her not notes of mixers [ __ ] me
okay here we go
I hope you like color look it's cool and
foggy and even putting cream in that no
it's just [ __ ] panicked
a lot of it Chris
to be fair you should have been a fuller
glass more clue on how they would have
been better and Queen in separate on
flight oh hi daughter ship because I'm a
glutton for punishment
I didn't even know he had cream
available he went back for a second so
you know that means it means he loves it
[Laughter]
Thank You Man Ralph consistency looks
great so it's very again if we're going
for white Russia very wide you probably
used a lot of cream I can tell you use a
[ __ ] ton of cream just by what's coated
on the glass
yeah it is it's my special edition to it
I'm excited to try it I don't know if
people saw me but I see an empty wrapper
on the table so I can guess can you
taste the special ingredient it's a lyft
drivers a milky it's a milky way from
Sam's a left ride better than come on
man it's also really high just drink it
already we can't try mine no he's been
drinking that great dragon okay you went
heavy on vodka and you would have me on
Kahlua but it's there now mine's darker
but dude that's a perfect light rush I
try yours you see it I'm gonna try my
own that's what a white race you're
supposed to look like I went for the
same way Roger
chocolate syrup to mine because I like
to party
well that's against the rules knees
pretty spider that's spot on
try mine yeah yeah but he has ice in his
it's you're gonna like it better
everybody get the [ __ ] outta tickets
over that yeah yeah I like that it is
ice sea yeah it tastes better this
tastes good because it's chocolate syrup
but you don't add chocolate syrup to
White Russians it's not white russian
anymore in fact she's got a dirty
Russian I don't know I don't know if
that's true my personal favorite for the
very first time it has been my own
cocktail I did it I did it my case why I
said I like mine the best yeah yeah yeah
didn't have enough booze in it every
other time I was trying to be there's
only so much here let's hear the actual
ingredient can we hear some give me some
ice for my fun break your friend drink
[Music]
no [ __ ]
and I think it if we're going by that we
should have ice they're supposed to ice
at first pour it over us no I think he
did all he did all of it because I mine
doesn't have ice in it
congratulations again I've never lost
one game out of we do this our fifth I
wanna beat him was [ __ ] Lachlan and he
was a goddamn bartender for 10 years
can I get some ice for my wine please
God how many times do I have to [ __ ]
ass don't throw stuff at me dude no
you're completely to begin with do you
want some more Cola my wife I know that
much fun every [ __ ] week every single
week is a great time
however every time however long it takes
for this to come out or whatever Jesus
listen I think what we found out is that
we have fun yeah
there's butter finger on my wine glass
I'll [ __ ] tell you did you guys throw
away the rest of those grapes oh I got
this everybody hold your own glass no no
no go you're on White Russian nope yeah
Samuel it's not white pick up your
doodoo ah ha ha ha it's just classic
Creek waters everybody thanks for
watching you guys
[Music]